Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here's a very disturbing, disturbing COVID
conspiracy theorist who called in. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Yo, PAC man, total control 871. Yo,
what's up with the surge? From what I understand,
the COVID is surging again. But why does it
always surge in the communist controlled states?
The deep blue states where it's surge.
Surge surging. Oh, my God, it surges.
What can I say? I'm sorry. Sorry about that.
You know, the surge, it catches one unawares.
And what can I say? You know, guys
like me over 50 shot free and COVID
free for some strange reason, I never get sick.
Speaker 1: So this is what we call extrapolating
inaccurately from an anecdote. There are tens of
millions of people who have not had COVID, and
some of them are unvaccinated. And the fact that
this caller didn't get COVID and isn't vaccinated
tells us actually nothing about the pandemic.
Speaker 5: That's so weird. It's almost like
the pandemic doesn't exist.
Speaker 1: Right. And and so
that's what we call extrapolating too far. He
didn't get sick, so it must all be imaginary.
Speaker 5: We know that's crazy talk.
You know, that's a conspiracy charge.
Surge to surge. Oh, surge. Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
Sorry, Dave. That was a real surge was a real
strong surge. Oh, my God. That was. Oh, I
think I almost went blind with that one.
Oh, my God. I just surge all over myself.
Speaker 1: All right. So as you can see, these are
not exactly the types of folks that you can really
speak rationally with. That guy actually called
in to the show once, about a year and a half
ago and is talking points were pretty similar.
It's tough to get everybody on the same page
about basic facts when you've got people who
believe stuff like that, that that's where we
can leave it. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. Won't even tell you what's
on it. You'll just have to tune in to see
get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at join Pacman dot com and
you can use the coupon code big voting
22 to get a discount if you so choose.